et vieru bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ça fait plaisir que
j'ai re on a eu l'occasion de discuter
de votre mandat en période électorale en
2019 dans le cadre d'une élection qui
était à date fixe est ce que ces
différentes de vérifier les promesses
des partis politiques quand l'élection
vous arrive comme ça de façon imprévue
le travail en lui-même est
essentiellement le même la grande
différence c'est qu'on peut pas se
préparer de la même façon que lorsque
les élections sont à date fixe et on n'a
pas la même durée aussi pour évaluer
l'ensemble des promesses qui ne sont
soumises parce qu'il faut bien deux
c'est à la demande des partis politiques
qu'on estime le coût de leurs promesses
électorales donc plutôt d'avoir 120
jours la période au cours de laquelle on
peut le faire pendant une élection à
date fixe on a uniquement du moment où
la campagne électorale est déclenché
jusqu'au moment des élections dans ce
cas-ci 36 jours ce qui est beaucoup
moins de temps que 120 jours en période
normale pour le commun des mortels
qu'est ce que c'est votre meilleure
période électorale et partis politiques
viennent nous voir et nous disent est ce
que ça a du bon et c'est ce que je suis
en train de remettre les partis
politiques peuvent venir nous voir pour
nous demander d'estimer le coût de leurs
promesses électorales le coût des
promesses qu'ils envisagent de faire
donc il nous demande uniquement
d'estimer le coût ou les revenus qui
sera générée par des nouveaux impôts des
nouvelles taxes par exemple on leur
fournit les estimations coup ci il
prévoit toujours annoncé ces mesures là
il nous avertit si nous ils nous
informent lorsque la mesure est annoncée
et à ce moment là on divulgue
publiquement l'estimation de coûts
dans le cas où les partis politiques ne
procède pas à l'annonce de quelque chose
qui nous ont demandé d'estimer on doit
garder sow confidentiel donc on ne peut
pas divulguer les renseignements pour
lesquels les promesses ne sont pas
rendus publics donc c'est comme s'ils
s'étaient jamais arrivé en effet nous
pouvons dire qui vous a demandé de
vérifier quoi vous me dire combien de
demandes indépendamment des parties
comme une demande de reçus jusqu'ici je
peux vous parler de l'exercice de 2019
au cours duquel on a version environ 200
demandes au total oui c'est beaucoup on
en avait publié 115 donc le 115 de ses
demandes le qui avaient été publiées ou
promesses qui avaient été faites et donc
environ 85 90 qui avait jamais été mise
de l'avant par les parties pour diverses
raisons ils n'ont pas l'obligation de
nous donner les raisons pour lesquelles
ils sont parlés pour l'exercice actuel
étant donné qu'il est un exercice
confidentiel qui est pas encore complet
je peux pas vous dire le nombre de
demandes pas encore mais je peux vous
dire qu'on est très très occupés depuis
que la campagne électorale était
déclenché comme il s'apprête en face à
travers une promesse ou pour analyser
une promesse en promesse d'un parti x ça
dépend toujours de la première si on dit
qu'on va augmenter un taux d'impôts
existants ou baisser un taux
d'imposition
c'est assez facile à faire parce qu'on
on a des
ddd programme ou du modèle qui nous
permettent d'estimer ça mais si on parle
de d'instaurer un nouveau programme
comme par exemple un programme national
d'assurance médicaments que le npd a
annoncé vendredi donc le fait prendre
beaucoup plus de temps ça peut prendre
quelques semaines dans l'école est plus
complexe par exemple si on n'a pas les
données déjà au bureau s'il faut qu'on
aille chercher les données ailleurs et
si on n'a pas de modèle existant pour
estimer une proposition en particules
dans un contexte comme ça vous utiliser
les ressources que vous avez où vous
aller chercher les ressources
supplémentaires on existe on utilise les
ressources qu'on a déjà on est une
quarantaine au bureau dont une bonne
trentaine qui sont en mesure de faire ce
genre d'analystes danalyse pardon là on
peut aussi demandé l'un de la fonction
publique soit pour avoir des données
accès à des données dont on ne dispose
pas encore ou encore de l'inde pour un
style mais certains certaines
propositions donc on peut avoir recours
à une aide extérieure mais on essaie de
faire la très vaste majorité du travail
alain terme pour éviter évidemment des
fuites parce que c'est les questions qui
sont particulièrement sensibles en
campagne électorale vous avez vous déjà
demandé le quai qui profitait le plus de
votre travail est ce que les partis
établis les plus petits partis
est ce que quelqu'un qui en tirent
davantage de bénéfices je dirais que
ceux qui en tirent davantage de
bénéfices ces problèmes en les électeurs
lorsque
ils voient les provinces des partis
politiques et qui sont rassurés à
l'effet que l'estimation de coûts a été
fait de manière indépendante et non
partisane
ils peuvent avoir une plus grande
certitude que c'est les meilleurs estimé
possible mais aussi les parties basé sur
l'expérience de 2019 je peux pas dire
que c'est davantage les petits partis ou
les parties plus établis selon moi c'est
l'ensemble des partis politiques peu
importe leur taille et leurs ressources
qui en bénéficient vous avez parlé de
l'exercice en 2019 tout à l'heure des
200 quelques analyses que vous aviez
fait qu'est ce que vous avez appris de
cet exercice là qui vous a aidé cette
fois ci
on a appris que les mots qu'on utilise
pour par exemple qualifié le niveau
d'incertitude relié à l'estimation
peuvent être mal interprétés par exemple
en 2010 neuf on utilisait des
qualificatifs pour dire qu'une
estimation de coût donc le coût auquel
on arrivait avaient un niveau
d'incertitude moyen élevé ou faible et
ça a été mal interprétés dans certains
dans certains médias ou par certaines
certaines actions qui étaient en jeu
lors des élections de 2009 comme étant
un jugement de valeur sur la proposition
est le même donc on a appris de ça on a
appris aussi que les partis politiques
n'arrivent pas dans une élection avec le
même niveau de préparation et le même
niveau de raffinement quant au
développement de politiques quant aux
détails auxquels ils ont réfléchi donc
on a on a vu que un service comme celui
que la loi nous nous demande de fournir
est très utile pour certains partis
politiques qui n'ont pas n'ont pas la
capacité de réfléchir au même niveau des
temps que d'autres par exemple et je
vous remercie fille ça me fait plaisir